Speaker 1: OK, we have lots of news to start
with today.
Some good, some not so good and some absolutely
terrible.
And we're starting there.
What is taking place right now in the country
of India is almost beyond words.
It's a complete humanitarian crisis as hospitals
are collapsing under the pressure of a covid
explosion.
If you look at the numbers, I looked this
morning and thought there must be a mistake.
It looks like they are almost literally off
the charts.
And in fact, these numbers I'm going to show
you were probably underreported due to the
poor infrastructure in much of India.
That is leading to people just dying in the
streets.
That's not a figure of speech and potentially
not even being counted in the number of dead
from covid.
So cases in India have surged to a pandemic
high of three hundred and twenty thousand
cases per day.
India previously had just one peak in mid-September.
They did a good job for a long time.
This new peak is more than three times worse,
their previous peak and the deaths are just
as bad, spiking most recently to about 2000
deaths per day.
And again, probably under reports of the real
numbers because of the disconnected and rural
nature of much of India, where we just don't
even know if these numbers are actually the
full story.
Now, I think it's important to understand
as we sit in the United States and look at
this, that because of India's high population,
India has one point three, almost one point
four billion people.
We have about 330 million here in the U.S.
We still have higher per capita case rates
and per capita death rates than India from
the start of the pandemic.
The difference, of course, is that we never
saw rates of growth like this.
If this continues for even two more weeks,
we could have a dramatically different story.
And the level of hospital collapse that India
is experiencing is different than what happened
in the United States.
We did get to full ICU use and we had a very
brief period where we were getting to the
limit on ventilators.
But what's happening with medical facilities
and supplies in India is tragically almost
unbelievable.
They are out of ICU beds in many places.
They are out of oxygen in many parts of the
country.
I saw one report last night where they were
reporting from the main sort of meter for
the hospital's oxygen supply.
It was just at zero people being left outside
of hospitals waiting for care.
Some are just dying in the streets.
The images are absolutely horrifying.
New Delhi in particular, which doesn't produce
its own oxygen and is dependent on getting
help from other areas, it seems to call it
critical shape doesn't even really explain
what it is that's going on there.
A bunch of Delhi hospitals tweeted essentially
S.O.S. messages over the weekend saying we
need oxygen supplies.
At least 20 critically ill people died on
Saturday after oxygen supply was delayed.
They ran out and it took a period of time
before they were ever able to get more.
Other countries are trying to help, but it
feels like it's started too late not to be
critical of people that are helping.
But we saw this coming and we fortunately
now see Joe Biden sending ventilators and
PPE and test kits and more medications.
Many other countries are doing the same.
The UK is sending ventilators.
Many countries are doing things, but arguably
too late to help many of the people that are
dying daily at this point in time.
And yes, there's also some vaccination happening
there relatively slowly.
Some countries are sending more vaccines.
We know from looking at the numbers here in
the US, it takes a while for the vaccines
to make a difference.
You start vaccinating after two weeks.
That first dose provides 85 or 80 percent
protection that you need excuse me, that second
dose, and that is a slow process before it
makes an impact.
Vaccination won't solve the current problem
happening in hospitals as we speak, with three
people dying every two minutes.
Also going in very much the wrong direction
in terms of larger countries are to some degree
not like India, but the Netherlands, Germany
and Colombia are also seeing some modest upticks
in terms of larger countries.
And by the way, my birth country of Argentina,
just a continued disaster there with a completely
incompetent leadership, lack of transparency,
strict but unenforced rules.
Vaccine cronyism, one.
Elected official found with vaccines in his
trunk and said, oh, I was bringing them to
some hospital, I mean, just about everything
you can imagine, it's been happening in Argentina.
I have friends who just flew down, vaccinated,
said that accurate mask wearing was at about
50 percent.
Shop owners are all wearing masks from what
you read, but you walk in and the mask is
down over the throat like, you know, it's
a complete and total disaster.
And the numbers there are also reflecting
that.
So globally, you know, you actually need some
nuance to see what's going on.
You have some large countries like India that
are disproportionately making the global numbers
look bad.
We see a resumed case decline in the United
States.
We are now about three weeks from when Israel
saw cases go down 90 plus percent.
It looks like we are going to start seeing
very good numbers last week I said we were
four weeks away now.
Now it looks like we are three weeks away.
And then at the same time, if you look at
just the global picture, you say, are we really
making any progress here?
We are, but we're also losing ground in certain
places.
And it's going to be this will go into twenty,
twenty two.
When you consider that many countries won't
even really be able to start vaccinating in
a serious way.
Until then, never mind the issue of vaccinating
children, we hopefully are getting closer
to that.
Submitted for approval on one vaccine for
Pfizer has submitted for approval on 12 to
15.
They did that at the beginning of April.
We should be days from the FDA reviewing that.
And hopefully we can expand that to 12 plus
so many different things to be looking at,
some good, some not so good.
And what's going on in India.
Absolutely terrible.
Which makes this next story particularly difficult
to pass.
The European Union will be opening to vaccinated
American travelers at some point this summer.
Let's talk
about
that next.